[Music]
a charter school for girls is closing
forcing students to Now find another
school eight news now education reporter
Joshua peguero looks into what led up to
this closure
girls empowerment Middle School also
known as gems opened in 2020 dedicated
to helping low-income families but three
years later principal Joyce Brooks says
gems is closing getting funding and
backings from people in the community is
something that you know a lot of
non-profits rely on to keep going and
that's something that we just couldn't
secure enough funding to be valuable the
school made the decision Monday due to
low enrollment and funding the assistant
principal says a large number of the
student population are Black and
Hispanic our families aren't in a
position to uh to donate or pay tuition
and as a public charter we don't charge
a tuition and so we really rely on the
state funding the state public charter
school Authority voted for a gem to
submit a financial plan on how they plan
to survive until June 2024 but gems
could not submit one the state Charter
School Authority says in a memo that
without higher enrollment for 2024 and
Beyond it was likely the school's
financial Outlook would continue to to
deteriorate gems only had 70 students
enrolled for the next school year we
know that closing mid-year is not an
option so we need to see what is a what
is the plan to make sure that the you
know the school completes this this
school year and if possible what
evidence and support information can
they provide us to show they can make it
through at least next school year on top
of the funding issues multiple people
have left gems with State officials
saying this leaves the board with six
members three vacant seats and no school
leader Joshua progero 8 News Now